it is seven o'clock good to see you this
wednesday morning and indeed we have not
one but two big breaking stories for you
how much more are we going to get
squeezed the latest inflation figures
are out shortly and why is there anger
over the compensation for victims of the
worst treatment disaster in the history
of the nhs the infected blood scandal
we'll be getting reaction from a
survivor and indeed from the senior
cabinet office minister kit malthouse in
just a few moments time plus are you a
grafter we'll be asking liz trust
supporter sergeant javid about a comment
from the tory leadership at faith
favorites that's had not had the best
reception it is wednesday 17th of august
could inflation be about to hit double
digits we'll have the very latest
figures shortly and i'm here in one of
the most deprived parts of england to
find out how people here are coping
anger and disbelief the government
offers compensation to the victims of
the infected blood scandal but
others affected will be missing out
how can they have this differentiation
in this hierarchy between bereaved
families
i mean all their lives matter just as
much as the next person
a weed ram of criticism liz trust called
grossly offensive after a leaked
recording reveals her saying british
workers need more graft
what needs to happen is to me
more graft
but it's not a popular message
spiteful and sanctimonious donald trump
hit sites at republican liz cheney after
she loses her seats in congress we'll be
telling you why
a route to safer roads or just far too
many rules could cyclists soon be forced
to have number plates and insurance
weather warnings with more rain on the
cards we'll be taking you through the
latest flood alerts
also ahead on the program
[Music]
charismatic and funny tributes to the
singer darius who died at the age of 41
but mystery surrounds the nature of his
demise
and shining the spotlight on covet we'll
be focusing on the pandemic at half past
night speaking to the world health
organization and an author about her
long covered recovery
[Music]
morning all uh we begin as advertised
with some breaking news the latest
inflation figures are out our business
correspondent helen ann smith is sitting
directly opposite me with them in her
hands so what are we learning i suspect
it's not good news i'm afraid it is yet
more terrible news another really big
jump in the rate of inflation to 10.1
percent inflation was in the 12 months
to july 10. that is the first time we
have seen inflation in double digits uh
since
the 80s since the early 80s another
40-year high i say this every month and
we've been doing this for about 11
months in a row now 11 months in a row
we've had above target inflation we have
to remember the target that we would
like inflation to be about two percent
so 10.1 percent it really is huge and we
are all feeling it in our day-to-day
lives there's some real drivers to it
it's food it's fuel those are the two
really really big ones but what i think
is really frightening about this is we
are although it might not feel like it
in a slight calm before the storm moment
at the moment because when those energy
prices go up as they will in october um
things are going to get worse the energy
price cap i mean the forecast just
change every few days up and up could be
as bad as in excess of 4 000 pounds a
year in excess of 4 500 pounds a year by
the spring i mean really big numbers
we've had news today that the gas prices
in europe are going up again because of
the low levels of water in the rhine
people trying to
build up their stock so all of these
factors means things are probably going
to get a lot worse uh in the in the in
the autumn there could well be a
recession i hate to be such a doom and
gloom monger but it really is a bleak
picture this morning helena will we'll
have much more from you throughout the
program on this particular topic for now
thanks very much
now it has been called justifiably the
worst treatment disaster in the history
of the nhs
the thousands of people infected with
hiv and hepatitis c through contaminated
blood products in the 1970s and 80s well
this morning compensation has finally
been announced for survivors and spices
but there's anger from some children and
relatives of those affected who will be
missing out our home editor jason
farrell has our first report
my name is andrew evans and i was
infected through hemophilia treatment at
the age of five with hiv and hepatitis c
i
developed full-blown aids at the age of
16 and barely managed to survive to the
age of 20. andrew is one of an estimated
4 000 victims who survived what's been
labelled the worst treatment disaster in
nhs history where patients were infected
with hiv and hepatitis c through
contaminated blood products it's thought
around 2400 people died many suffered in
silence because of public attitudes to
hiv the stigma was still so strong
against those people frightened me to
death
and so i kept everything completely
under wraps as far as that was concerned
i told nobody at school
um
i didn't tell even my best friends about
it
um until it became absolutely apparent
that there was
uh you know something going on that i
was ill and i couldn't hide it anymore
evidence social care shall be the truth
shall be the truth after decades of
campaigning an inquiry was launched in
2018
former health secretaries and a prime
minister gave evidence no one accepting
blame or the argument for compensation
what had happened to them was
incredibly
bad luck
but campaigners say it was incompetence
reckless blood collecting methods in the
u.s and a lack of checks when imported
to the uk
the inquiries recommended compensation
and now the government has announced
each victim will get a hundred thousand
pounds obviously it's a very welcome sum
of money
if you split a hundred thousand pounds
over forty years of being infected it's
two and a half thousand pounds a year it
will help at the moment
for me personally to do
what i want to do most which is to
secure my family's future but i'm also
very aware of the people this doesn't
deal with at the moment
i'm lauren denise palmer and i lost my
both my parents
back when i was nine years old lauren
was orphaned by the scandal her father
was given infected blood and died of
aids in august 1993. he unknowingly
infected her mother who died in the same
month
while spouses of victims will get
compensation parents who lost children
or children who lost their parents won't
get paid
how can they have this differentiation
in this hierarchy between bereaved
families
um i mean all their lives matter just as
much as the next person i haven't been
able to lead a normal life as such where
i've got the stability of having two
parents
for support and
to go through education and go to uni
be able to stay at home long enough to
save to put a deposit on a home
so i haven't
haven't done any of that
this is a victory for people like andrew
but decades late and many like lauren
who've suffered are still waiting for
recognition jason farrell sky news
a very significant day uh let's discuss
it with the chancellor of the duchy of
lancaster kit mo his ms martin's lovely
to see you and
we we've certainly got plenty to talk
about in terms of the way the scheme is
being administered when the payments
will start going out but i wonder if we
might start but by just giving you the
opportunity to speak directly to the
victims of this scandal and indeed those
who have been bereaved by it this was
something that just simply should never
have happened oh look without doubt it
is a dreadful episode that has had a
very profound impact
on too many people and some of the
stories certainly that i've read have
been tragic i mean the report which led
to this payment today includes the
testimony of a number of
people who've been deeply profoundly
affected in their lives by this event
and it's very very moving um and so it's
as i say while uh money will never
compensate for what's happened uh i'm
pleased that we're able to make these
payments uh today
given given the huge pressures on on the
kind of the nation's finances at the
moment why has the government chosen
this particular moment to finally move
forward on on sir robert francis's
recommendation well it became clear uh
during the early part of the inquiry
that was set up in 2017 uh that um the
impact on people had been such that
compensation was going to be
payable uh so my predecessor penny
morden commissioned
robert francis to have a look at the
framework for compensation out of that
came the notion that because of the
urgency of this matter and the fact that
frankly people were dying
that we needed to make an interim
payment that went to the main inquiry to
brian langstaff who made a
recommendation uh which we've complied
with fully um and so we're announcing
today that we're going to make those
interim payments of a hundred thousand
pounds uh to uh those infected and brave
partners um and we'll be making that
payment by the end of october i mean you
mentioned urgency there i mean given the
fact that people are dying at the rate
of what one every four days
those who are affected by this urgency
it is of the essence that this gets done
as soon as possible so why then many of
those who are affected by this are
asking are they going to potentially
have to wait until the end of october no
so at the end of october is the deadline
by which everything has to be paid so
the money may flow uh more quickly than
that obviously the advantage of what um
sir sir robert and so brian have uh
proposed is that there's a current
support scheme on which all these people
are enrolled that is making payments to
them of varying degrees uh to deal with
their care that allows us to identify
those individuals quickly and make the
payment quickly so my my uh october date
is a is a deadline by which the payment
has been made hopefully it will be made
much earlier why has it taken though and
you don't need to to delve very deeply
into the inquiry to find people who feel
that this process has taken far far too
long
so francis is recommending so robert
francis's recommendations as i recall
were handed to the government back in
march
you had the chair of the inquiry so
brian langstaff suggesting at the end of
july that interim payments were to be
made we are in a situation and i
understand that you are committing to
get this done as soon as possible but
you're also suggesting that people may
well have to wait months to receive this
payment why is it taking so long no
so you're right that robert francis
reported earlier this year but that then
went to the main enquiry he appeared i
think in in july in front of the inquiry
and the responses came to us um at the i
think at the beginning of july uh we've
moved as quickly as we possibly can to
get all the the the complexities if you
like of making this payment through to
make sure it's not going to affect
people's eligibility for welfare that
won't affect their taxation situation
all those kind of issues we're now in a
situation where it's been approved it's
through the treasury we can start to
make the payments as quickly as possible
so look we're very apprised of the need
for urgency on this as you said um
estimates are that somebody's dying
every four days we died last thursday
exactly so we need that money to flow as
quickly as we possibly can and that's
exactly what we're going to be doing
over the next few weeks but again just
in terms of the chronology of all of
this some are suggesting that what the
government is trying to do here is in
essence minimize its liability and in
the most brutal horrible way possible
they're suggesting that people are dying
of course a rate of one every four days
that could be 20 dead by the end of
october robert warwick is an example of
all of this quoted this morning in the
guardian he was infected with hiv and
hep c he says this the government have
held off as long as they can simply
because the more people die the less
they will have to pay out in the end so
the scandal continues speak directly to
richard well i'm afraid that that's i
understand why people are anxious about
the time frame but i'm afraid that's not
correct and and to be honest with you
that you know there's a very dedicated
team at the cabin office we've been
pushing very hard uh to to make sure
that we get all the the teas across and
the eyes dotted so that we can get this
money out as quickly as possible you
know part of my job has been to drive
that through with them through
government over the last month we now
have to make sure that we get that money
out as quick as we possibly can we're
all appraised for the urgency and i
understand after you know for some
people a 40-year
campaign uh to get to this point that
they're anxious and impatient now for
the money to be out and we will do what
we can to get out as quickly as possible
just be absolutely clear are you saying
that this process has been carried out
at every point as quickly as it possibly
could yeah certainly uh you know i came
into the job whatever a month ago and
i've seen nothing but alacrity from the
team and we've been pushing hard in
every department dhsc the treasury have
all moved at speed to get this money
flowing 400 million pounds as quickly as
we possibly can we're now in a position
where we're able to pay it as i say to
those who are infected and indeed to
bereave partners but don't forget neil
this is this is an interim payment
right so there's a contemplation
particularly in the framework that sir
robert produced that in future when the
inquiry finally concludes which we think
will be next year we'll then be able to
contemplate what more we
we morally need to do just in terms of
that moral obligation lauren palmer who
you saw in
in a report there she lost both her
parents when she was just nine years old
what about people in her situation what
about parents who lost their children i
mean we know that successive governments
have in essence lied to cover up what
was the most fundamental scandal within
our health service it seems pretty clear
that those individuals like lauren
deserve some form of compensation can
you give an assurance today that they
will be getting something at some point
so
the claims that you make and the
eligibility and the scope
of where
where this terrible scandal impacted and
what should then happen is exactly what
sabrina langstaff is looking at in his
inquiry now it will be wrong for me to
prejudge that that will come out next
year he's due to conclude as i say in
2023 i i understand once he has been
it's not the position of the lawyers
representing representing the victims
this is what they've said the infected
blood inquiry continues its good work
under sir brownlong staff however it
would be frustrating if the victims have
to wait for the inquiry's final report
before a meaningful compensation
mechanism is put in place they continue
they have already waited decades and
this is the key point any argument that
we need any more evidence of the fact
the government must be held to account
is now untenable we know that the
government responsible we know that
these people need compensation why can't
we simply move forward well that's why
we're making interim payments uh now you
know we saw the the need for that early
on in the inquiry that's why we got to
robert francis to put together this
report on a framework for compensation
payments and while he's obviously
recommended interim payments that
framework is good for future
compensation payments as well we have to
wait for the inquiry to conclude as i
say uh infected and brief partners will
get this money quite quickly over the
next few weeks and then we'll be able to
consider once the inquiry is concluded
the more complicated questions about
wider eligibility and what if any
compensation should be payable of course
the victims of infected blood they're
not the only people who are desperately
seeking compensation so what about those
who've been affected by primitives
valproate and mesh the cumberland review
two years ago recommended that they
deserved compensation and still the
government is sitting on its hands since
then 23 members of the prima dos
campaign have died when will they get
compensation well as i say today we're
concentrating on the infected blood
scandal we'll we'll have to consider
more widely uh these you know medical
events from from past years um but you
know i'm happy to look at that situation
as well and see what can be done it just
feels again given the complaints about
the length of time it took for the
inquiry to even be set up then for the
inquiry to move forward then having had
this interim report passed it started
having had this compensation report
passed to the government then an
argument at the end it just feels again
that the government is dragging its
heels and when people are genuinely
dying you know week after week after
week because of mistakes which were
avoidable these are people who never
received the compensation that they were
due
well look there's no doubt about it that
the the many years of campaigning that
lots of people put in uh should not have
had to happen right there should have
been a as far as i could see an early
acknowledgement that uh there had been a
an issue that a tragedy that a scandal
had unfolded um in 2017 obviously the
government did recognize that and
instituted the inquiry we're now moving
to fulfill the recommendations on
interim payments as quickly as we
possibly can having recognized early on
that this was likely to be the case my
job now is to to drive that through and
make sure the money gets into people's
hands as quickly as we possibly can but
look there are more complicated
circumstances uh that than we are
currently addressing around eligibility
not just infected and brief partners but
there are others as you said parents
children other relatives now that is
more complicated as sabrina langstaff
has said in his inquiry and we will get
to them in the end there's remember this
is an interim position
um and i'm pleased to them in the end i
mean that's the assurance that people
are looking for well certainly that's
where the inquiry is going right so when
so brian made the recommendations the
government which were fulfilling today
he did acknowledge that would be
disappointment in some other groups that
it was more complicated uh to work out
eligibility and scope with them but that
in time we would get there
can we talk about about the big major
news the other breaking news this
morning of course inflation cpr hitting
hitting 10.1 i mean your response to
that pretty grim times but also perhaps
comment from you
on why we have to wait until the 5th of
september to find out what this
government is going to do about it
well look obviously the whole of the
developed world is is struggling with
with inflation at the moment as you know
caused by global
energy price shock and supply chain
difficulties and not least the war in in
ukraine so it's it's a struggle for
everybody uh but it wouldn't be right to
say that the government is is sitting on
its hands i mean as you know that we've
got 37
000 million pounds 37 billion pounds now
flowing into people's pockets which has
pretty much been wiped out well about
which we've just seen in terms of
inflation but a lot of that is that
there is a desire to see here right now
what the government is going to do when
we're in limbo for three now i
understand that but um much of that is
yet to land
right so the the support payments that
will flow out i mean in total there'll
be about 1200 pounds to a third of
households across the country at the
lower end of the of the pay scale who
will get that assistance there's
obviously money that will be flowing
later this year to pensioners to people
with disabilities and there'll be money
flowing generally through bills to
support people across the economy um
we're obviously in a political
transition period uh so when a new prime
minister arrives they will have to make
some decisions about if any or what any
uh further support mechanisms might be
but it would there's no other country
but on earth where the senior members
the senior members of the government are
literally sitting on there well they
basically you keep saying that and
that's not true either so you know i had
a meeting just last week with nadeem
zawi chancellor to talk about the
different elements of of the of the of
the economic package that might be
available to a prime minister while the
current 37 billion flows out so they're
able to make decisions quickly alongside
that don't forget we're still running
our help for households campaign they're
working with the private sector to see
what they can do to assist um there's
lots of work ongoing uh a to get
ourselves in shape but b to promote and
push out the current support schemes
which are pretty huge by our standards
what is the prime minister's level of
involvement in any of this
well as i say the prime minister i think
he was at the the meeting with the fuel
companies the energy companies uh just
last week between these qualities to
monitor what they're doing um and uh
he's staying in touch and being briefed
by a staff at number 10 i would imagine
mr martinez it's a busy day for you
we'll let you crack on thanks thanks a
lot
let's have a quick look at some of the
papers and we start with the ft it shows
uh official figures um the real terms
wages are falling at their fastest rate
for 20 years which likely means that
inflation will be coming under control
anytime soon
british workers need more graft says
less trust that's on the guardian front
after the emergence of that
controversial audio clip we'll be
discussing that a little later
well the express uh has this trust
attacking eu bosses for breaking a
research agreement uh in her view to
punish
the uk over brexit
the times meanwhile leads with rishi
sunak turning on liz truss over the cost
of living warning that her plans to ease
the crisis
will tip millions of people into
destitution
plenty coming up on a very busy
wednesday on the programme a year on
since the taliban returned to power in
afghanistan i'll be joined by a female
former afghan mp to discuss what the
future holds for the country's women and
girls
shortly after eighth labour's shadow
home secretary of ed cooper will be here
to discuss labour's response to the cost
of living crisis
[Music]
and a little later that hour the
managing director of iceland richard
walker will be here to discuss the
supermarket's new ethical food credit
scheme
donald trump has hit out at the
republican liz cheney as spiteful and
sanctimonious
after she lost her seat in wyoming to a
candidate backed by the former president
our international affairs editor dominic
wagon has the detail
in a farm in wyoming the cheneys came to
accept defeat liz cheney the latest to
most high-profile republican victim of
donald trump she has lost her seat but
she says the fight against him has only
just started this primary election is
over
but now the real work begins i have said
since january 6th that i will do
whatever it takes to ensure donald trump
is never again anywhere near the oval
office and i mean it
liz cheney's been an implacable opponent
of donald trump and voted to impeach him
and has now paid the price her opponent
in this conservative rural state
repeated trump's lie the election he
lost was rigged in turn he came here to
campaign against liz cheney and
predicted this outcome
and it's why in two months from now the
people of wyoming are going to tell her
liz you're fired get out of here
get out of here
[Music]
but cheney's defiance in defeat is
increasing speculation she might take
him on herself
this jenny has stopped short of saying
she'll run for president in 2024 against
donald trump but she's using this defeat
to renew her fight against him and her
team say she believes it could make her
stronger
[Music]
the wyoming election has again
underlined the strength of the trump
faction among republicans his supporters
want him to announce his running soon
behind the wheel of his customized 71
pontiac bob ferguson says it's just a
matter of time all the stuff that's
happened since he's been out of office
has probably convinced him more and more
that he he wants to be president again
and wants to to redeem what uh
what's been done against him cheney's
defeat shows the power of trump even
from the sidelines and the republican
party's divisions as potential battle
lines start to be drawn ahead of the
2024 election
dominic waghorn sky news wyoming
oh well after hearing the results donald
trump took to his truth social app
congratulating the winner and guess what
hitting out at liz cheney
uh this is a wonderful result for
america he says and a complete rebuke
for the unselect committee of political
hacks and thugs
liz cheney should be ashamed of herself
the way she acted and her spiteful
sanctimonious actions words and actions
towards others
now she can finally disappear into the
depths of political oblivion where i am
sure she will be much happier than she
is right now thank you wyoming
i think yeah i think donald trump may
well be off liz cheney's christmas card
list but let's turn our attention to the
weather
forecasters are warning torrential rain
and thunderstorms could hit parts of
england and wales today a yellow weather
warning for thunderstorms is in place
from peterborough to birmingham and
through to the south west of wales the
met office says there is potential
danger to life from flooding and heavy
rain in parts could cause disruption to
transport systems and possibly power
cuts
these are some of the latest pictures we
have from across the uk after torrential
rain one
resident in loughborough managed to
capture this photo of cars
surrounded by water in their local
supermarket car park
and the flooding also caused disruption
in wales in port talbot
houses were damaged by water and cars
became trapped by the flooding
a similar story story in ireland uh
roads there were left damaged by
flooding in new ross county wexford
and a young boy you can see here
battling with an umbrella very patriotic
umbrella on the south bank just a short
distance from where we are in
westminster
uh but let's leave the weather plenty
instead to talk about in the tory
leadership race this morning after last
night's hustings and a leaked recording
of liz trust saying that british workers
need more graft let's speak to one of
our supporters the former chancellor
former health secretary sajid javid mr
jab lovely to see you again good morning
um
can we start of course we have just had
in the past few minutes the the latest
cpi inflation figures 10.1 percent
eye-watering and we know the direction
that it apparently will continue to to
carry on
given the fact we are three weeks away
uh from the next leader of the
conservative party the next prime
minister being announced
shouldn't liz trust start talking rather
more explicitly today about what she
intends to do to deal with the cost of
living crisis well i mean i mean first
of all i'd say we don't know who's going
to win this leadership race um i hope
it's liz trust i think they're both
great candidates by the way like any
party member i've got to pick one i
picked liz i think she's got the the
best plans for the future uh so that's
the first thing that said of course both
the candidates but especially liz has
been setting out what her plans would be
on this most important of issues the one
fixing our economy
is mentioning what any of the the
measures would be in the emergency
budget which she tells us will be coming
but she won't tell us anything that will
be in it well i think i think she's
already said a few things that will be
changes in when it comes to the economy
so for example the tax cuts and i think
they are especially important for
long-term growth we we can't tax our way
into growth and she set that up it's the
shock cost of living crisis that's the
problem and the measures that she's
announced including the rollback on on
the national insurance increase they do
nothing for the person well she's also
announced uh a she's going to freeze the
energy levies on bills for at least a
year and that will help but but i think
she's also recognized that
a lot more will have to be done and the
right way to do that is that if you
become prime minister is then to with
your team then is to sit down and work
out take into account the latest picture
the latest evidence we'll have more
information for example on the price cap
by then and to decide but to do it very
quickly and she's absolutely right to
say there will be an emergency budget i
i would assume the treasury is already
working on plans from an incoming new
prime minister they will present those
two to liz and her team and she will act
very quickly and that's what's going to
matter i'm just i'm just i'm just want
to concern that perhaps the situation
isn't tenable over the course of the
next three weeks particularly given the
fact you have seen you know the heather
being satellite by the labour party's
announcement on an energy cap freeze
over 70 of conservative members
apparently it's supported as a policy so
you've got the opposition coming out
with concrete policies and you've got
liz trust you know touring the country
admittedly speaking to party members
admittedly but repeating the same stuff
over and over again
you know when when you're in opposition
you're never going to be held
accountable for what you say so you say
what sounds good i mean i i listened to
what kirsten had to say yesterday i
don't think his numbers added up at all
you know liz is campaigning to be prime
minister and and if she wins she has to
deliver on everything that she said so
she's thinking very carefully about the
commitments rightly so and she's made
some solid commitments but one of those
clearly is to have this emergency budget
which as i say will happen within weeks
and to take further action nothing has
been taken off the table because she
recognizes as i do and as i think most
politicians do is that this is a very
very serious crisis for for families at
home they would have looked at that
inflation number today and whilst it
might not be a shock because of what the
bank of england said recently that
doesn't make it any less palatable to
anyone people will be worried and liz is
going to be the right person to deal
with this we will have to wait then for
the for the emergency budget but perhaps
just in ideological terms you can tell
me i mean which of the two does she
prefer does she think that support
should should be blanket and as indeed
labour's policy is or does she feel that
that it needs to be targeted
specifically at those most in need i i
think you don't have to choose between
the two i think that you if you look at
the approach so far from the government
there's been a a combination of a
targeted approach to people on certain
incomes there's been
an approach where everyone
gets money off their energy bills uh
what she has said with the tax cuts of
course that will benefit everyone uh but
you know having a look at if targeted
action can be taken i'm sure that will
be considered when it comes to the
emergency budget
can we talk about the the delete
recording that the guardian have uh have
uh uh have managed to obtain in fact we
can we can probably bring it up and just
workers um
produce less per hour than
and that's a combination of kind of
skill and application what needs to
happen is to me
more graft
what did she mean by that well
that comment as i understand it was made
a number of years ago i don't know the
exact context that was made in but i
understand that liz trust has changed
her view in a variety of things over the
years but what i also what does that
mean you heard her say just in that
snippet that you played there uh was
that the productivity in the uk versus
other comparable countries is generally
lower and that's been a long-standing uk
problem and that doesn't happen because
british workers don't work hard british
workers are amongst the hardest working
in the world i mean i ran the health
service and i can tell you they could
not work any harder in the health
service
it has also also said in that there was
a difference in productivity between
those working in and around the capital
and those working in the regions she
appeared to be suggesting the problem
with those in the regions is that they
don't graft hard enough when everyone
else knows the reason that the south
does better is because business and
investment has been focused in this part
of the country to the detriment of the
rest of it i think what she's talking
about is business and investment because
to increase productivity the the
government of course is a huge role to
play there's capital investment things
like infrastructure investment for
example those areas that get more of it
generally of course it can do better in
terms of productivity it's also about
skills
investment and making sure that we're
investing in skills here across the
country not just in the capital or the
southeast but you're right across the
country and and that is what's going to
make the difference and now liz has a
plan for that but it all comes back to
the economy because if we don't increase
our growth rate we won't be able to pay
for those investments and that's why liz
has a plan that says look you've got to
start with tax cuts to kick-start growth
you've got to make a number of other
changes of course alongside that but it
starts with tax cuts and she gets that
one thing that both liz trust and rishi
sunac have studiously avoided committing
to or even mentioning the 40 new
hospitals that we were hearing that we
first started hearing about from boris
johnson back in 2019 at beth rigber
political editors has done a bit of work
showing that 80 of them either don't
have a completion date or are unlikely
to be finished by the next general
election isn't it about time that we all
just admit that 40 new hospitals was was
a nonsense no of course not because the
first of all the commitment to 40 new
hospitals is by 2030 not by the next
general election the next general
election is not interesting you'd expect
them to have a completion date however
you would expect that plan to you to be
a plan in place that's going to lead to
the 40 new hospitals by 2030 that plan
does exist of course it needs uh some
updating not least given the inflation
figures we've just talked about uh but
liz is committed to our manifesto and
that includes of course the record
investment that we're seeing in the nhs
how many of those 40 or new hospitals
all 40 will be new hospitals there's 20
alongside that there's 20 hospital
upgrades which is more or less all of
that's been done there's 40 new
hospitals and and that is the commitment
in our manifesto and that commitment
will be kept by liz just just one other
topic again on journalism by one of my
colleagues debra haynes um
has an exclusive story that the raf has
effectively paused recruiting white
males to to hit diversity targets the
head of raf recruitment in fact
resigning in protest
on at this effective pause what do you
make of that well first i'll say i
haven't seen the detail of that story
but let me go uh which is sometimes
dangerous let me just go on what you
said i i always take you at your word
and you'll give it to me straight uh and
and based on what you've just said it
sounds like complete nonsense
to me i don't think any organization
whether it's the raf or any other public
or private organization should be
recruiting on the basis of one's race of
course we want to see a diverse
workforce we want to see all talents uh
come through and i happen to think
having more diversity actually increases
the productivity of your workforce but
it should not be based on race whether
it's black white or anything else so
java lovely type in the studio thank you
thank you
quick reminder that if you scan the qr
code that will be appearing on your
screen right now you can listen to the
latest edition of the sky news daily
podcast on today's episode chloe culpin
looks at the environmental promises made
by both rishi sumac and liz truss in the
battle for number 10 and asks where
we're heading to next on the road to net
zero you can subscribe for free to the
daily you'll hear my voice on it again
next week wherever you get your podcasts
uh tamara corner political correspondent
here in the studio as always um right
let's let we've spoken on two uh issues
the leadership contest and indeed on
infected blood with kate morris and
sergey javid your thoughts
look inflation has hit 10 today and if
you're wondering what the person most
likely to be our next prime minister liz
trust is going to do to help people with
their bills
when it goes up and continues to go up
in the coming months all we're hearing
is nothing is off the table she really
doesn't want to set out what kind of
support people would get under her
government other than saying there will
be an emergency budget at the end of
september she'll already be prime
minister by then if that happens the
decision will already have been made
we've heard so many different forms of
wording from her supporters some people
say she favors a more targeted approach
you heard sajid javid there saying you
can do targeted as we've done already
there's 650 pounds going to the most
vulnerable but you can also do help for
everybody that sounds exactly like sort
of handouts that liz trusted she didn't
like there's also tax cuts which as has
been pointed out by various people
benefit what the wealthiest more even
her opponent rishi sunak says
millions of people could be at risk of
destitution if list trust does not give
support or offer support to everybody
who will need it we heard some muted
criticism of labour's plan saying
perhaps the sums don't add up not really
attacking the the principle of it attack
actually on labour's plans than i think
we had for we haven't heard yet because
they they're trying to say look this is
they're trying to say this is you know
fantasy labor don't have to actually
implement the policies they suggest but
look
at the moment liz trust is still being
studiously vague about what support she
would give to people allowing others to
project their ideas onto her tamar thank
you
let's stick with those breaking
inflation figures this morning it is of
course in double figures now at 10.1
fraser mods joining us now from a
community hub in burnley the lancashire
town one of the hardest hits by the cost
of living crisis and i suppose these
these official figures at phrase are
just confirming what those who live
where you are right now already know
life is tough and it's going to get a
hell of a lot tougher
it is indeed sadly the announcement of
the figure today 10.1 isn't really going
to change people's lifestyles from
yesterday to today just knowing what
those figures are here in burnley
highest inflation rate in the country
it's about 2.4 percent
below that uh average of of 10.1 it's
about three percent lower than it is in
london so the people who use the church
on the street here for the food bank for
the cafe for the drop-in centre and so
on they're the hardest hit people in the
hardest hit region of the country and
the man who runs the this project here
uh pastor mick fleming just
give us your thoughts on this 10.1
percent worse than the prediction more
bad news yes daya but what he's doing is
he's creating a new port he's creating
the working poor and that's something
that's very frightening because when
you've got people who are actually
working or can't sustain
a month-to-month lifestyle just just by
eating getting to work traveling there
we're in trouble we're in serious
trouble so is that what you've noticed
over the last months as this credit
crisis the cost of living crisis has hit
us it's the type of people who are using
centers like this yeah the dynamics have
changed so there's far more old age
pensioners so we're catering for that
which we didn't have any uh and more and
more people were working and they can't
get to work so they're having to come to
uh just helping with bus passes to get
to work on the last week of the month
things that you necessarily won't think
of people can't get to the doctor's
surgery because it's too far away and
they're not well enough to walk
so they need bus fare so and
everything's gone up you know
everything's going up uh it's not so
it's not just the food it's a knock-on
effect that we're seeing yeah okay
thanks very much for talking to us the
cafe here opens in about an hour or so
and uh the flood of people will start
coming in about a thousand people a week
or so they help here and things are
probably going to get worse than that
pretty soon
fraser many thanks
nice cyclists may have to get a licence
and insurance to ride their bikes soon
after the government has suggested it
will tighten rules to bring them in line
with car users and crack down on
dangerous cycling uh joining us now uh
sky's correspondent matthew thompson
matthew don't step to your left
obviously and just explain exactly what
is going on here this is the this is the
beginning of a consultation process call
me an old cynic but i've heard stuff
like this from the government before
yes this is basically the transport
secretary grant chaps having given a
couple of interviews to some newspapers
this morning in which he said that he
thinks that cyclists should be subject
to the same rules and limits as motor
vehicles on the roads which raises the
possibility that cyclists might soon
find themselves getting license points
or fines for speeding and running red
lights and the like and it comes just
a couple of weeks after the transport
secretary also said he wants to create a
new offense of causing death by
dangerous cycling but you know there are
two obvious flaws to this plan from the
transport secretary the first is the
reason that speed limits are so easily
enforceable against cars and the like is
because well they've got number plates
so should cyclists have them as well mr
shaps tells the times he doesn't think
so but clearly some sort of identifying
markers would be required otherwise how
do you enforce it the second flaw is
that well mr schatz may only be the
transport secretary for another three
weeks and let's say that announcing
major new policy initiatives just weeks
away from a cabinet reshuffle under a
new prime minister is at the very least
we might say neil hostage to fortune
matt thanks very much indeed
let's take a quick look at some of the
day's other headlines now
saturday this an elderly man riding a
mobility scooter has been stabbed to
death in west london the attack happened
in caton road in greenfield annealing
just after 4 pm on tuesday met police
officers were called to reports of a man
with stab injuries
despite the efforts of paramedics he was
declared dead at the scene there have so
far been no arrests
the former pop idol contestant and
theatre star darius campbell dinesh has
died at the age of 41.
[Music]
well the singer was found unresponsive
in his minnesota apartment
because of yet death is yet to be
determined the music mogul and former
pop idol judge simon cowell paid tribute
calling him charismatic funny and just a
great person to be with
some other famous faces have been paying
tribute
michelle heaton says her thoughts are
with darry's family right now always our
brittany
and nikki chapman one of the judges on
those shows back in the day uh she
tweeted this to say a true gent
with a kind soul and a mischievous
twinkle in his eye from that eventful
first audition on pop stars to him
kindly inviting me to see him perform on
the west end stage
now a year after afghanistan fell to the
taliban some of those who worked there
for the british are still in hiding
there in feet of their lives one former
british army interpreter has told sky
news that his life has become hell and
called in the uk to help him escape
from the afghan capital of kabul our
chief correspondent stuart ramsey has
this report
the checkpoints haven't moved the blast
walls and protective paraphernalia built
by western forces remain in place
now manned by the very people they were
put there to stop
there's no war now but the country
remains on a war footing
taliban special forces crisscross kabul
the islamic state bomb threat is a
constant but life here is relatively
normal exactly a year ago it was very
different we filmed the chaos of the
evacuation of people who lost in these
crowds had served the british government
and military for two decades
people promised safe passage to the uk
many never made it to the gates of the
processing center at the barron hotel
next to the airport
well it's obviously much quieter than it
was exactly a year ago
this is the
baron gate this is the area that people
were brought in to be processed by the
british military and this was the chaos
outside the scenes here
that basically shocked the world it's
still a restricted area
they don't really like you filming here
at all and just beyond here you can see
and it's hardly changed in the year uh
the canal uh where
a lot of people were killed in a suicide
bomb attack which basically brought this
rather chaotic evacuation to an
end with the taliban fully in charge
hundreds if not thousands who are
qualified to enter the uk are now
effectively on the run
fearing for their lives
we won't name him but this man served
five years at cambastian for the british
military
he's still waiting for news of a plan to
extract him
he's confused by the delay and he feels
abandoned and overshadowed by another
war
one here is a very long time
just look at her what's the difference
between my blood of gun bloods
and
lucrative bloods
the uk they eukaryotic crime give
hundred thousand visa for them they are
worth for one month and still
one years now i'll go
why they all do this like
with me
do you feel angry do you feel sad what
do you feel towards britain i don't know
so i can explain to you sir she's very
my feeling is very bad my life has now
become like a hell
i don't know what should i do where we
can work
composed throughout our interview he
finally broke down when i said sky news
would try to help him and his wife and
two children
we can see if we can get the ball
rolling
and we'll talk to our guys and they can
talk to you i really appreciate it just
very kind of you because
i don't know what's happening the next
day the next year the next tomorrow i
don't know
i love my family so much my children
but now i can't do anything
i don't know what should i do for my
life and my family will be growing
why they not help us
one year on people like this interpreter
are hiding in family homes moving every
month unable to work unable to send
their children to school
living in fear and waiting for
instructions that they think may never
actually come
stuart ramsey sky news kabul
i will here to give us their thoughts on
what afghanistan's future might well
look like
one of its former mps farzana kocha
fazana lovely to have you on the
programme uh this morning um
you last spoke well you spoke to us back
in in august of last year and and you
know you were very skeptical about
whether or not the taliban would stay
true to its words
on women and girls being allowed to
carry on in education and work you were
right to be skeptical weren't you
uh yeah thank you um
[Music]
unfortunately
uh what we saw in uh last one year with
uh is that uh we were we were right
and we are right taliban never
cared about women and women's rights
human rights and
to their promises about keeping everyone
safe and sound
uh so we just saw a report
that says so many things
what sort of life
will afghan girls have without that
education without the freedoms that they
had before the return of the taliban
um
before the return of alban
no i i'm asking what what what is life
like for afghan girls at the moment
given the fact that they no longer have
education that they're being told whom
to associate with there is no prospect
indeed of them being able to return to
work i got it thank you sorry i just
went to another place
and that's um
obvious uh
life for girls uh in afghanistan and for
women just became a hell like this man
that you have had the interview with
there is no there's nothing like looking
at the families
society level and the government level
there is nothing that women can
have
women do not have an economy in their
household
do not have food do not have medicine do
not have anything they have been true
they are going through so many things
like violence women are the first
especially girls who are facing the
wireless and who are paying the price
for the poverty in all those economical
situations in the society they do not
have a place to go they are being
removed step by step bit by bit they are
being
removed from the society they don't
belong to those streets
they are told that you do not belong to
here and the institutions the most
important thing that there is no address
that women can reach and can go and to
solve their problems
so the situation for women like we do
not have a present and by not having an
education which is the most important
thing that we do not have a future
if we do not have education we do not
have a present and of course not a
present we do not like
the only hope that we can have is to
have an education and to be hopeful for
the future which we we cannot see now
for farzana
the the west appears to believe that it
can somehow force the taliban to move on
on human rights and rights of women by
withholding you know the gold reserves
by holding the cash reserves you know
600
million pounds worth 600 million dollars
worth
held by the world bank at the moment and
the problem of course with that is as
you will well know massive parts of
afghanistan are suffering now from
malnutrition there is a breakdown in
terms of health care in the country the
country seems to be grinding to a halt
yeah um
most of the sanctions or the policies
that
are now imposed on the taliban are
basically um affecting the people's life
it's not about the taliban for example
if we or just
come out to something concrete and much
beneficial that can be imposed on the
taliban is the travel ban why not the
travel ban on the taliban leadership
which can be
just uh renewed by the 19th of august
now so they are
always
doing everything that they want
traveling they have all the things and
tools that they want and they need but
those
things that financial
things that you mentioned the sanctions
are basically affecting the life of the
people if we are doing things like the
afghan students are abandoned from the
taking part and especially
just see the uk in the
scholarships and so on um and people are
suffering from the poverty and hunger in
afghanistan but taliban do not care
about those things they say they they
just clearly said that ask god for the
food we are not responsible for your
needs and
things that you
should have
so
these sanctions and these policies can
be concrete and much more
in a way that can
influence or can
bring a pressure on the taliban like the
travel ban that i just mentioned
farzan i'm i'm i'm so sorry to interrupt
you but we are completely out of time
thank you so much for talking to us i
think i think people will have
appreciated your perspective on what's
been going on thanks again
a little bit of breaking news to bring
you a host pipe ban is to be brought in
by thames water on august the 24th
we'll be bringing you news of where that
will be in effect in the next hour but
it is my understanding
that it will be pretty much in all of
the areas uh that thames water supplies
water too
no major shocks no new announcements at
last night's tory hastings in perth but
both candidates did dismiss the idea of
a second scottish independence
referendum let's get a sense of how the
race stands with under three weeks to go
at delta joe twyman back in the studio
good to see you joel um yeah so so so
hustling's taking place in in scotland
and of course there is a real question
about what effect either leader might
have on on the push for scottish
independence mind jimmy and everyone
said boris johnson would be the biggest
gift to scottish independence but still
we're not quite over the 50 like uh yeah
that's right it's it's difficult to know
given how little that both candidates
have talked about scotland and certainly
prior to the prior to the hustings in
perth last night it's difficult to see
how either candidate would have a major
impact on on that and uh and there has
been a poll of scottish uh scottish
voters prior to the hustings uh but that
showed that
actually there was very little
difference between the candidates people
are extraordinarily bad at predicting
their own behavior particularly in
hypothetical situations such as this and
what the poll results show is that
actually
the scottish people have a pretty low
view of
both candidates that's what we can
conclude from this but just just to
stick on this just for a second i mean i
was speaking to em to an sn pmp
yesterday and i made the point to him
that sometimes you know you often it
often feels like the conservatives are
taught as if they're you know a
non-entity in scotland and that's not
the case 25 percent of the popular vote
in 2019 in scotland absolutely but the
scottish conservative party is on many
occasions not least when it came to uh
to the latter days of of boris johnson's
uh uh boys johnson's reign
it was a very different party from the
conservative party in westminster and so
i think that's what we're seeing in the
polls an astonishing bit of polling on
the on our second screen here and it
seems like a majority of people in
including conservative voters
supporting the the energy price cap
freeze uh proposed by the labour party
this is staggering 72 well
yes but it's inevitably of course more
complicated than that this poll was
commissioned by a campaign organization
who are campaigning for precisely that
but that doesn't mean that they're
polling and this question is not
legitimate because it is a legitimate
question but what you're seeing is a
reflection of the strength of feeling
people are very upset and also very
worried about potential price rises in
energy and indeed the cost of living
more generally and so solutions such as
a a cap
extending the cap at the current level
will inevitably prove popular are you
noticing any effects by the reticence of
both camps uh both camps and this to
come forward particularly let's trust to
be perfectly honest with you to come
forward with the concrete proposals for
tackling the cost of living crisis it
seems we're all having to wait until
after september the 5th yeah it really
doesn't surprise me at all it's a really
really complicated and difficult
situation and because of the huge amount
of money involved there are no really
good answers or any least bad answers
now people at home may be saying oh what
about nationalization like they did in
france well nationalization cost france
eight and a half billion pounds to buy
what was left of edf but they already
owned 86 percent of edf so to
nationalize the the big five companies
in this country for instance would have
an enormous cost attached to it and
getting people to comprehend that is
very very difficult joe always great to
have you in the studio get your
expertise thanks very much for joining
us
stay right where you are of course as
you can see the bottom of the screen uh
the infected blood scandal a story that
we will continue to cover but those
inflation figures cpi now at 10.1
percent what could that mean for
communities up and down the country
we'll be taking a look after this
[Music]